oh I love this section it's called
defending the first series where we
expose the enemies the First Amendment
free expression and free thought the
latest target of campus censorship and
the epidemic there is renowned history
professor emeritus Burt Folsom of
Hillsdale College an approval committee
at Davidson College in North Carolina
tried to ban him from delivering a
lecture on campus the committee's excuse
well they claimed the lecture would not
be academic enough let's bring in
Spencer Brown he's a spokesman for the
group that invited the professor to
speak young Americans for freedom we
have other stories to get to as well
they ultimately Spencer allowed him to
speak on campus but not at a particular
venue which is bigger and they put him
off to the side somewhere and they said
well you can speak over here the
unwashed professor what's going on yeah
that's exactly right and I don't think
it's any secret to you or your viewers
that there's a real crisis in
ideological diversity on college
campuses but what surprises us
continually is the excuses that liberal
administrators use in order to shut
these speakers down so here we have
Davidson College telling us that Bert
Folsom who's at one point had the number
one best-selling history book in the
country is not academic enough to speak
on the main part of their campus it's
just ridiculous well it's a fraud and
there's another hilarious story campus
reform went out and they decided to
interview students about sending troops
to the border and immigration and so
forth let's watch when President Obama
did it I felt that there was I suppose
different coverage as to what the
intentions were I draw the line yeah who
can be here or not the students didn't
know that President Obama had actually
sent troops to the border and so they're
like well when he did it we what what is
your take on the the lack of just basic
understanding of whether it's the
Constitution or just basic recent
American history it is a constant
demonization of Trump or the propaganda
machine on college campuses for like 50
grand a year a lot of these plays yeah
well that's the real tragic part is
these are students who are going to
school allegedly to get an education
become well-rounded and instead they're
not learning critical thinking skills
they're not learning
to defend their ideas they're just being
fed this problem of leftist ideology and
so what you see here is these students
who don't know why they may support or
oppose this policy all I know is if
Trump supports it it must be bad whereas
if you had asked it the other way around
if Obama had supported it you know
they'd say it was the greatest thing
since sliced bread yes so that was at UC
Santa Barbara and so well you didn't
show it in this video is before they
didn't know that Obama sent the troops
to the border so they kind of like had
to back into that oh well when he did it
it was necessary it's just it's classic
this is classic uninformed god bless
them uninformed college students who who
learn it for the first time from some
radical professor radical history
professor then at GW University right
nearby where we are the Democrats some
of the college Democrats are not
participating in some type of bipartisan
discussion summit last week they don't
want to be bipartisan well it looks like
basically the leftists are showing their
true colors and that is they don't want
a dialog they don't want the free and
open exchange of ideas because they know
when that happens the best ideas rise to
the top and the flawed idea is the
left's ideas will fall off and so what
you see here is basically their goal is
to allow a situation only where leftist
ideas are heard because they know in
conservative policies and solutions are
offered those are going to the vines
pick right they don't have a side of a
debate I've never seen anything like it
they are the most the pusillanimous
they're petrified and they by the way
they said some members of the current
executive board have hesitations about
participating in events with
conservative orgs they're scared
petrified by Bach that's all I'll say
Spencer great to see it thanks for the
update